[Music]
in hired theft news Oh submitted by
submitted by it moist all caps was
another word that people don't like
besides moist boys the N word and the F
word oh that's right Nigeria another
word in France yes right French wait
what
that's them we said the N word in F word
Oh Nigeria in France yeah I love Nigeria
shots in Nigeria actually I don't know
anybody I think it anyways a shop owner
is seeking out skilled thieves to steal
from her for sixty four dollars an hour
that's amazing that is very smart
yeah I wanna see if the shoplifting yeah
yeah I know what the CIA does yeah
definitely they hire a bunch of hackers
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah it's also better
to take the best ones and have them on
your payroll
instead of like on somebody else's
payroll yeah rich because they can be
very very dangerous I want to be hackers
I don't know any backup Pierce I think
it's fun
well the prerequisite is gotta be smart
first and that's hard for me or in
general oh yeah you too not smart if I
were my character on taken yeah from NBC
I would I would do it it's cool man I
feel like hackers is like such a
romanticized thing when it's like in
reality you're sitting on your computer
for like seven hours straight and you're
just obsessed with that [ __ ] and
you just smell like flamin hot cheeto
and sweat oh my god that's amazing
and you also can't do what the movies
say you do you can't like I've seen
movies where they like change the
traffic lights hmm why'd you can you
can't you can't do that how do you know
that how do I know that they can't
change traffic lights dude he was on
taken you understand he was
he was three steps removed from Liam
Neeson's himself alright I think more
like or like or like hack into like
government files yeah or like some
subdued smartphone that isn't even on it
like I've seen it like on a smartphone
Oh ruin the movie magic for me this is
all possibly glad you're saying that
because then I feel better with my
smartphone being off right right that's
what I'm saying there's some crazy [ __ ]
dude have you guys seen so recently I
watched a an anime film and I wanted to
see the behind the scenes of it so
Muriel and I wanted to watch it dude if
you've ever seen some of the most
overworked human beings on they look
like hackers but there was a guide that
I felt bad for laughing but it was just
imagine a dude that hasn't showered for
six days but he's like 60 years old he's
balding and his hairs all out this way
like so how do you feel about this
project and he's like saying in Japanese
he's like smiling he goes I haven't
slept in five days and I put my work in
and sometimes they tell me my stuff is
trashing oh my god I started bursting
out laughing cuz I thought it was a
sketch but it was real [ __ ] like that
was it a documentary it was a document
that they made when they were making my
which I can't Akademi or something it's
like an anime that you'll see or do they
leave that in there but that's like the
work schedule they have in Japan though
you are like we're there that's normal
that's normally look at the dedication
exactly it's like already it's like a
overworked industry but it's already in
Japan which innately is culturally very
in Korea I think they passed a law no
America was telling me that they passed
a law where the company has to shut down
by midnight so what they'll have the
reason why is because there's this
culture in Korea it's cool but it's not
at the same time because it's like
overachieving right so if one guy
doesn't leave the workplace they're like
well I can't look bad so I have this
depends like that yeah so there well I
have to stay so everybody stays up till
5:00 a.m. yeah because they don't want
to look like the lazy person in the
workplace so now
my mom got bullied and and mind you
she's getting bullied at like 60 years
old when she was working this like 50 to
60 a night right like people out there
still bully like pretty [ __ ] hard
right so so because she wouldn't do the
game of pretend overtime like everybody
else she gets bullied for that and she's
like [ __ ] I gotta go home and take care
of my mom like [ __ ] yeah and then she's
like [ __ ] the work culture out there
she's like I Miss America yeah she's
like what the health care and everything
so good so when they say they shut the
business at 12 I mean they know
electricity at 12 there's no way you
could work in the building because this
like you have to go home we're not doing
this [ __ ] where everybody should
outdo each other where you're gonna work
till death month done everybody has to
go home well if it's still an extreme
aachen extreme yeah yeah I don't know
unless you work in film then it's
whatever I don't know if they do this in
Korea but like so out there like if they
give you five days of vacation right
people usually come back in like three
Oh My Jesus no one gets to do five Wow
didn't want like that Wow yep they don't
want to look like they're uh they're
like mooching off the companies like
purging my mom even does that here she
worked for an American company here and
she never wanted to be the first one to
leave so like she goes she gets off work
at 5:00 she's still there working and it
she'll like look out of the corner of
her eyes okay cool it to people that
three people left and they should pray
and I'm leaving I'm like 5:35 for even
though it's just here I mean it's it all
in her head and everyone said oh it's
five o'clock we have the right to leave
I'm not getting paid anymore for this
uh-huh but just because of her own
cultural thing she's like I can't I
can't be the parents like what
hard-working aspect of like Asian
culture like Japan Korea Taiwan whatever
but then then there's no emphasis on
mental health family health and all of
those stuffs mental health don't exist
yeah yeah that's so funny too cause like
when I was at work I would wait for the
first person leaving with yep that's the
time the guy was the first person
like you were the signal dude I'm like
the signals up let's go
man we even we glorified in the West -
in sports oh yeah yeah yeah cuz you know
the Kobe mentality is like oh it's like
outwork the other person else and free
throws a day yeah you leave it you leave
it 12:00 I'm like no I'm staying till
3:00 I'm doing 1,000 just because you
want to be the best you want to be the
best and so in a workplace yeah but when
everyone's the same it's just like I
want to be the best customer service
since the baby this is AP MVP - Jeremy L
how can I help you did you as an owner
of a clothing store in the UK posted a
job offer on bar comm where what viral
so she's offering leave fifty pounds an
hour to come in and try to steal from
her store plus the chance to keep three
things that they managed to steal from
her and so she's saying that she knows
it's weird but she said this I'm looking
for a professional to help highlight
security weaknesses in my store by
deliberately stealing from it I've been
a business owner since I opened my
retail shop in 2013 and have experienced
extensive theft every year and the
run-up to Christmas for the last five
years like clockwork from the start of
November the shop gets busier and it
becomes harder to monitor everyone who
comes through the doors
people steal how much [ __ ] what no
bark calm is where I should posted the
job offer oh I thought people were still
Alicia's and like
like ex-con all tatted up and he's like
[ __ ] looking around and it's like a
squeaky toy he's like right what he
wants out she keeps thieves keeps wiping
things off the shelves and she's losing
thousands of pounds every year and as a
small business owner she can't afford to
let it slide so she wanted to hire
actual thieves even though there are
like like security professionals that
can can go and like assess the whole
thing she's like no I want people to
come in and steal and one of her
requirements is that you can't have a
criminal record because oh don't get
caught right I was really hoping the job
interview would be like looking at the
resume like oh okay
grand theft auto nice robbery that's
nice you're hired when you when you open
up a business there should or you should
know this already there should be a
percentage amount that's already given
as a loss for for theft and other stuff
it's like ten percent and that happens
with any and every small business is
something that you cannot help internal
theft mm-hmm yeah who's placing [ __ ]
happens hooking people up sometimes you
just give your customers stuff at cause
yeah phat batches all that's it's armed
men like with like learning having that
I for knowing when somebody's gonna
steal something is something you develop
over time too cuz I mentioned the store
before but when I was younger and my dad
told me like you'll watch these people
they're gonna steal I used to think that
he was just being lightweight like
prejudiced you know but then when he let
me run the store the way I wanted to we
had everything store all your customers
are black and you thought dad you're
racist exactly and it was just like to
the point where I was like you know my
dad explained to me he goes it's not
it's not a racial thing it is if you
give somebody an opportunity to steal
something they're gonna do it not
because they're bad people it's just
it's just there it's almost innately
human to think you don't know everyone's
situation if they're desperate exactly
or whatever reason people do a lot of
dumb things it's like you can't look at
Evers perspective as you want to look
stupid you have to think about the
business and he goes I don't look at
people like like my race or color it's
more like I know how human beings are
and if human beings have an opportunity
to do something that they want they'll
take that
tunity like we've had hit the biggest
lesson that he taught me was there was a
lady who who I saw coming to our store
consistently and she she stole from us
move my [ __ ] mind
ice obviously since grown up as a
[ __ ] kid and she stole a wig from us
and I was like what the [ __ ] bloom
because I would I trusted her so much I
would just look away when she came to
the store and she would just shop there
everything and my dad was like don't do
that she's gonna steal something
no you won't let me do my own thing she
stole away it was like cameras we have
cameras righted the the videotape back
and I saw it she [ __ ] stuck in her
person she left said hi invited me and
everything else and you know that was a
lesson for me it was my dad's life she's
gonna come back to store I'm a letter
come back I still think she's a good
customer but I have to watch her so
she's deterred from doing that right and
I had to learn that lesson I was like oh
[ __ ] it's just more like when people
have an opportunity to do something if
they just might do it yeah cuz it's like
I'm gonna buy this soap anyway but if
they're not looking I'll get it for free
but if they are looking then I'll buy it
yeah and they're kind of about area two
so that's like that's ignorant on my
part too that's just the culture that
you know what I mean like when we were
younger my friends used to still a lot
to what makes me think that I'm any
different from them if I would have done
it why wouldn't they do it too you know
just saying like yeah maybe I could come
in and tell us where we have holes in
our whole system here like if maybe we
can move camera positions or move like
the inventory the way it's set up so and
then Bart's calm they got they were
asked about this job request and they
said the co-founder said like well I
mean we do have security professionals
already on the site but professional
robbery isn't a service that we actively
offer but if there's a lot of applicants
then maybe it might be something we do
offer on the site I mean it can be from
security companies that submit on their
own to like hey we hired you know guys
that don't have a criminal record but
they're they stole mmm nice in your
wallet good I wonder I wonder if it'll
be like a career progression for an
aspiring thief now it's like it's no
longer like I'm just gonna keep stealing
stuff but it's like I want to steal
stuff to get good enough to get noticed
by a security company and then I'm
sponsored then I
yeah you got to make your mouth you got
to make your rounds first you got to get
real good it's like a New York mobster
that's like one day I'm gonna own a
Vegas casino
[Music]